israel was an early leader in mass
vaccinations against covid19 the first
country to go for the booster shot now
it's looking to break new ground again
an expert panel has advised the
government to offer a fourth shot to
everyone over 60 to those who are
especially vulnerable and to frontline
medical staff i don't know i think that
there's a lot of
a lot of confusion and i feel that the
point what i do for myself and for my
children is uh follow the advice of our
personal doctor israel's prime minister
has called the recommendation wonderful
news and says he's impatient for final
health ministry approval
his campaign to increase the vaccination
rate among younger children though and
for the double jab to get their first
booster has so far fallen short of its
targets
combined with the hundreds of thousands
who've refused a vaccine altogether it
means about 40 percent of the population
is estimated to be under or unprotected
against omicron we are made a lot of a
interview interviews with the doctors
with the nurses
we are going to the schools to convince
them to come to have the
vaccine yet not all of them are
convinced like much in the world's
response to the sudden breakthrough of
omicron this is a decision that's being
made without the full information one
small israeli study into the effects of
a fourth vaccination has yet to report
its results nonetheless it's been
decided that this is an opportunity for
greater protection that's worth going
for
one public health expert says with the
efficacy untested promoting a fourth
injection could add to the mistrust of
those hesitant to be vaccinated so we
are doing
something that is unusual reverse
epidemiology we first do the
intervention then we studied it
it's not done in preventive medicine you
may do it in a severely sick patient
that you have nothing else to offer and
you say okay
we need to try something it makes sense
but you don't do it with preventive
medicine within the government panel
though the counter arguments won the day
86 of its members voted in favor of the
additional booster not for the first
time the world will be watching israel's
results harry fawcett al-jazeera west
jerusalem